hello my name is Alan Fogarty as a stray
I'm director of the global health and
emerging pathogens Institute and the
ican School of Medicine at Mount Zion in
New York and I've been working here for
almost 30 years working on virus
infections mainly especially influenza
virus and my group we like to call
ourselves the virus fighters because we
are trying to come up with new
strategies to prevent viral infections
especially influenza infections and
today I'm going to be talking about the
novel technologies that we are using to
study and prevent influenza virus
infections and what we are trying to do
in this field in order to reduce the
burden that influenza virus caused in
humans so my presentation is divided in
three parts first is how you use novel
technologies to study virus the
dominance of disease second part is
going to be how we use novel
technologies to identify hostile
appearing targets that can be used to
reduce severe disease in use by
influenza viruses and the third part I'm
going to talk about probably promising
but still early on vaccine strategies
that we are using try to come up with a
better vaccine against influenza viruses
the vaccine that we like to call
universal because it will be able to
prevent if it works any type of
influenza virus that is circulating or
consecrating humans in the future as
well as the ones that have been
circulating in the past so the main
topic of my talk is going to be
influenza viruses and here I just saw it
a picture of the electron microscope
that was obtained by my colleague yoshi
kawaoka that shows basically an
influenza virus in which one can see
these eight dots in the middle which
represent each one one of the RNA
segments of the virus we say segmented
RNA virus with a tiny segment and these
are rounded by circle which is composed
by a lipid envelope in which one can see
some spikes as in gray and these spikes
are the boundary approach things am i
glutenin and neuraminidase
age
and n that are responsible for the names
that we give to different subtypes of
influenza virus like h1n1 meaning
hemagglutinin subtype 1 nanometre
subtype 1 a3 and choose is 2n choose
h5n1 etc now in terms of our how many
influenza viruses we find in humans we
know about influenza since 1918 with the
pandemic 1918 occur and since then there
have been different types of influenza
viruses that are antigenically dear
friend and that means that if you get
infected with one of these antigenically
different types you don't get protection
against a different type and the the
types that have been separating humans
they are first of all infants of B
viruses and influenza A viruses
influenza B viruses kept in secret in
humans for a while and if one gets
infected with one influence of B virus
one develops good immune responses that
will be able to prevent infection with
exactly the same strain of influenza B
virus and the same thing happened with
influenza A virus now the problem with
influenza is that disables range like
people that has been infected before
because the VARs change from year to
year and through accumulations of
changes this is what is : T&E drift a
correlations of changes it becomes one
year that is so different from the virus
that infected one person before that now
it can evade pre-existing immunity in
this individual and country in fact it
happens both with influenza B and
influenza A viruses but influenza A
virus come off in different unique
flavors in humans there have been h1n1 s
H 2 n choose a three inches circulating
and these are what are known as the
subtypes each one of these subtypes
contains a hemagglutinin and
neuraminidase that is antigenically very
different it is a different number
his choice are different from H ones
these three are different formations and
when a new hemagglutinin comes and
jumped from a new type into humans
that usually cause a pandemic that what
happens in 1918 that h1n1 scam and then
cause the pandemic of 1918 continues to
see creating humans changing from the
archaea till 1957 II came a completely
different antigenically different virus
is to n2 that caused the pandemic of
1957 and these new viruses resulted in a
stopping of the circulation of the
previous viruses h1n1 not of influenza B
but in France I h1n1 these ones were
separating changing again from year to
year in 1968 of chemistry virus and that
caused the pandemic of 1968 again Avars
up is very different from these choose
each time that one of these types come
back come to the population what
happened is that because there is almost
no pre-existing immunity in humans
against this new type subtype then this
virus is able to infect more people that
normally seasonal influenza virus that
leads more infections and infectious in
general so more severe so these more
infections are more cases of severe
infections a three inches displaced a is
two inches and they were secret until
today changing again from year to year
and in 1977 h1n1 came back to the
population this didn't cause a pandemic
because they were practically identical
to the ones that disappeared in the 50s
but they started to consecrating humans
with these features and then finally in
2009 he came a new pandemic viruses that
we call it pandemic h1n1 is an h1 the
same one is was separating before since
1918 but the h1 was very different
antigenically to the h1 of the
circulating so this what make the virus
be able to cause a pandemic that
displays they all h1n1 and today we have
seed clearing humans h3 and choose each
one and ones and two lineages of
influenza B viruses so a total of four
antigenically different influenza
viruses and because of that the vaccines
that we have that they need to be used
every year to update the components of
the vaccine to
much the secreting viruses that have
four components to influenza B viruses
an h1 component under these three
component now but there are more
subtypes of influenza viruses plating in
nature and from time to time some of
these ones like h5n1 age 19 choose a
seven and sevens 879 they infect humans
there's a infections of coming not from
another human they come from an animal
reservoir and these infections sometimes
cause sensibilities but it's only in a
few individuals and the reason is
because there is no sustained
transmission from these viruses from
human to human but if any of these
viruses somehow why are the properties
of transmit well from human to human
than any of these viruses will cause an
elite now where these viruses come from
influenza A viruses they are not only
found in humans but they also found in
many different animals they are found in
pigs they're for horses they're 14 in
dogs in poultry and in one bird in one
birds there is a total of 16 different
subtypes of influenza viruses 16
different magnitudes and these viruses
are sickening Birds world birds they're
well adapted to these war birds but from
time to time they able to jump into
different species for example poultry
and they are if these thoughts just meet
the established limits in poultry simply
happen with swine the same happens with
humans with horses are with dogs so most
of the strains that are severe in these
animals they don't jump from one animal
to another but when one of these strains
jump and is able to acquire the ability
to transmit is when it's gonna cause in
humans a pandemic now I'm gonna start
first about how we use new technology to
study viral the terminus of disability
and for that I'm gonna give you an
example of the virus with which we have
been working which is the h1n1 of 1918
so this is the virus that caused the
pandemic of 1918 the pandemic that was
devastating and the worst pandemic that
we know of influenza viruses in humans
now this study is has been a
collaboration between multiple groups my
group together with a group of kiss bars
like Peter Pan I say here in Sinai but
also in collaboration with the CDC
special Terry thumpy the USDA David
Swain and at the armed force is
pathology where it was at this time with
our collaborator Jeff double burger now
what makes the 1918 pandemic influenza
virus are very unique well one can I
have choice lies that saw the
devastating consequences of this
pandemic the first one is the u.s. life
expectancy in the last century by age in
which we can see that from 1900 to the
2000s it has been increased steadily and
that's because of the modern medicine
techniques the use of high Genie
antibiotics better hospitals etc but it
was an exception and this exception is
this big tip that we have of more than
10 years and that was caused by
influenza virus that was caused by the
pandemic of 1918 the other slide that I
have that illustrates the potential
devastating devastating consequences
that this pandemic have it can is this
one that comes from a picture that is
been in the Smithsonian this a picture
of a village in Alaska that was taken
after the pandemic
1918 influenza viruses has affected the
village what is remarkable about this
picture is that they have these people
that are here in the picture they're
only kids there is no adults and that's
because this virus the 1918 influenza
virus has the ability a bat ability of
this lead to kill mainly adults that are
infected with the virus this is not
because the kids were not infected the
kids were also affected but in general
they survived infection and adults
especially in remote regions like Alaska
which probably was even less
pre-existing immunity against any
influenza virus these the consequences
of the infection with this virus was
very dramatic and most of the dolls so
commit from
this multiplexer in other regions not
all the bells died but it was also a
high proportion of people that they were
in age healthy adults individuals that
died of influenza virus infection in
1918 now why this virus was so special
why he is not happening with other virus
that has it raining right now
well this one we didn't know anything
about what could be the reasons for that
and the main reason is because of 1918
it was not known that influenza was
caused by influenza virus there was no
way how to isolate influenza virus at
this time and therefore the first time
that influenza virus was isolated was in
the nineteen thirties and this virus
although it was a descendant of the 1918
obviously didn't cause a most severe
disease as the parental 1918 virus now
the the mystery of this virus could have
been lost forever instead that there
were some samples that were preserve
where although these viruses were not
there as live viruses there were pieces
of the genome of the virus and our
collaborator Jeff diamond Berger was
able to get the sequence of the virus
coming from the samples one set of
samples came from lands of soldiers that
died in 1918 of influenza virus and they
were taking pieces preserving paraffin
and then stored in archives that they
were archives that they were maintained
by the army in order to allow future
generations for looking to what could be
the causative agent of a particular
disease in soldiers and I saw a picture
of one of these paraffin-embedded blocks
of a long piece of lung tissue from a
soldier that died in 1918 of influenza
virus and those samples came actually
from a village similar to the one that I
saw picture which a religion Alaska in
which after the pandemic happens that
the virus came then most of the dogs
died as as I saw in the picture and then
this adults were buried in a common
burial place under the permafrost lines
so the bodies were frozen since 1918
they were not in very good state the
virus was not there
but then dr. Shelton came to a grave
this grave did the grave and pick up
some samples in which the virus was not
there but the genome of the virus was
there with the genome our collaboration
with the f7 burger was able to sequence
the genome of date of these vials now
when new technology come is that we have
developed techniques that allow
reconstruction of an influenza virus
coming only from sequence so this is
base we know the sequence we can
synthesize the genome of the virus using
synthesis techniques for reconstructing
the genome as DNA and using what we call
reverse genetic techniques that allows
to go from DNA into RNA and come out
with influenza virus during these
reverse genetics techniques we were able
to generate back the 1918 virus from the
sequence of the individuals that died in
1918 of Spanish influenza or 1918
influenza and this was obviously that
was done in high bio containment unit
with our by our collaborators at the CDC
and now having this virus reconstructed
we can characterize what are the unique
characteristics of these spires both in
tissue culture and in animal models so
the virus was reconstructed and this is
a picture of the Landsat electron
micrograph and by the picture you can
not see that this virus could be various
inducing a very severe infection nearly
the sequence saw any sequence that we
know offer this time that was
responsible for severe infection with
influenza virus but this virus was is
very highly pathogenic and so when these
bodies put into animal models among them
for example ferrets which are believed
to be good animal model for influenza
virus because as humans they can be
infected with influenza virus and they
have a disease very similar to the human
disease when you put in ferrets if you
put in Faris's normal seasonal human
influenza virus and then you look to the
lung of the ferret you see a little bit
of inflammation but the land looks quite
healthy
so the
animals have a cold but a smile is not
severe disease however you infect the
ferret with the 1918 virus now the
lengths of these animals are
characterized by a lot of hemorrhage a
lot of infiltration of immune cells that
makes the lung full with fluid and
pneumonia high level of pneumonia and
the animal cell is unable to breathe
anymore and then die of 1918 influenza
virus infection now by we are being
working with this virus now since we
have reconstructed trying to understand
what makes this virus so different from
all the influenza viruses and the
summary of these results are is press
here in this slide the 1918 virus is the
only heal known human influenza virus
that is lethal to mice ferrets macaques
eliminate eggs and we know also it was
littering humans so it's a very special
influenza virus but the reasons for this
high mortality is not a unique risk
there are multiple genes that contains
determinants of civil disease including
four different genes hae na in this one
and P one of two different functions
during the viral cycle so you could
consider this virus a perfect storm it
just acquired multiple he had it had
multiple determinants of villains that
make the virus very special that makes
it very like that very difficult to
evolve again because it requires
multiple determinants of virulence in
early church choir these virulence in
humans now the good news is that if we
test existing antivirus against
influenza we can also actually treat the
1918 infection in in animals as well as
we use a vaccine based on age 101 the
vaccine is protective meaning that the
Bears like 1918
will be we will be able to still be able
to prevent infections with vaccines and
to treatment with existing antivirals
now I'm going to switch now and I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
host terminals of disease severity I
told you about these virus 1918 that is
especially virulent but seasonal
influenza virus normally induce a very
bad call but there is some people also
that have a disease that is very severe
and very similar to 1918 they are not so
many people as in 19
but this but there are some people that
die every year of influenza virus
infection so what makes a person more
susceptible or less susceptible to
influenza virus infections and we think
that these they are determinants in the
host in the human that are responsible
also for CP severity of disease so there
are no determinants for example come up
with these peoples that have
cardiovascular disease obesity diabetes
Inman and efficiency a chronic
respiratory disease these are more
likely to develop a severe influenza
virus infection and these are the people
that they really need to vaccinate it in
addition to the rest of the people but
these are the ones that get more
benefits from the vaccine now
co-infections girls increase the ability
of the virus to cause disease especially
secondary bacterial pneumonia and all
that is the age the old people you saw
they have a more severe disease
pregnancy also pregnant women they have
a more severe disease in general ours
still many apparently young healthy
adults that they don't get into these
different groups die of influences here
why so we think that they are happy but
this position in the genes that make it
more vulnerable to influenza virus
infection we're trying to figure out
what are the genes that make you more
vulnerable for some people than for some
others in order to identify the people
that may be most likely having severe
influenza virus infection so why is that
this is because influenza virus like any
Liars they used they need to use the
cell to propagate so the bars in the
cell and delivers the genome if rnase
inside the cell and inside the cell it
replicates and produced new variants
that come out of the cell and in this
process the virus is gonna need to use
some of the host
genes in orbit to help in the
propagation of the virus and in the
multiplication of the virus so by itself
the virus will not be able to propagate
requires us factors inside the cell but
also needs to deals with antiviral
factors because the cell responds to an
infection by producing and develop
actors have tried to prevent the virus
from replicating and killing the cell
and this is
in this combination of how the virus
deals with the host factors with
antiviral factors with a DNS cannot tell
whether one is going to have a more
severe disease or less severe disease
according to what is the sequence of
these factors now what are these factors
in order to notify these factors we are
using assistance biology approach we
called our program flu a mix in what we
are doing is we try to look at the
global level and these are the people
that are involved the emails of the
people that are involved in this program
we're trying to understand at the global
level what are the genes that are used
by the virus and in using proteomics
technique and genomics technique
metabolomics technique and figure out
what genes are important for the viral
replication both antibodies and require
genes and this is an example of what we
can do so here we have in general in
these circles we have the different
proteins of influence of ours and what
we have on the other signals that are
connected with lines we have proteins
that are known host proteins that are
known to interact with these factors
that have been identified through the
systems biology approach and in addition
they are represented here so not only
the proteins that host proteins that
interact with these bowel factors but
host proteins that if we eliminate them
from the cell they contribute to our
replication so this is a set of genes
host genes that now we have connected to
the systems biology approach that we
think are around 100 genes and we think
they are very important for influenza
virus replication so we are looking
whether they are human polymorphisms in
these genes that are associated with
severe disease but the other thing that
we can do with this information is we
can try to target some of these genes
for neon demons and that will be
inhibition of host factors in this case
I present an example here it a
collaboration that we have with
yamaraja here single sign in which we
denta find the host protein sex 61 that
is required for the export for the
transport of the virus glycoproteins
that are important for making the bars
in the cell and this was identified
through it
dynamics approach as interacting with
lipoproteins and there is an inhibitor
called ct8
that can be used against this particular
protein when we use this inhibitor then
when I want to inhibit replication at
all if inference around the cells of HIV
something without affecting the host so
that could be a potential good inhibitor
that would be able to fight against
multiple value infections not only
against influenza the last thing that
I'm going to cover is the issue about
influenza vaccines and we need we have
an influenza vaccine that works
understand why we need better vaccines
one of the reasons we need better
vaccine is because when a pandemic comes
there is no time for making a vaccine
that is against this particular strain
of influenza virus that is able to
prevent the disease and the transmission
of this virus this for example will
happen 1957 with respect of how rapidly
from the origin of these two into
pandemic how rapidly the bars
transmitted so it was first detected in
Southeast Asia in Ferren 1957 in May it
was always tended by a large area of the
world including Oceania and all
Southeast Asia and in August 1957 it was
expanded through the whole world and
that happens in 1957 was there was less
mobility of people buy for example
planes and they all saw the world was
not so populated like today so a
pandemic today transmitted with a speed
that is even faster that in 1957 and
what this means it means that by the
time that the new pandemic cars come and
you try to make a new vaccine then there
is the new vaccine comes late these for
example will happen in the 2009 pandemic
in the United States we see in red the
peak of viral infections in the first
wave in 2009 of the pandemic h1n1 blue
we see the production the shipment of
the vaccine against this h1n1 virus we
knew how to make a vaccine that you have
the vaccine ready to vaccinate the
people it was at the time with the first
wave or we're even now
so the vaccine didn't make an impact in
the first wave of the pandemic h1n1 he
was helpful for the next second wave but
not for the best wave if this pandemic
would have been as devastating as the
1918 pandemic this will have been a
disaster that fortunately that was not
the case
2009 was quite a neat virus while many
economic despite that there was also a
lot of young people that died in 2009 of
the pandemic influenza virus one of the
reasons because we may have a vaccine on
time now how the vaccines have been
produced the majority of the vaccines
that are against influenza virus they
are produced by taking a master
high-growth strain putting the ATA and
na genes of a circulating strain then
propagating the Briona index they must
restrain growth very well in in in eggs
and the secret strain provides hmm the
net genes your harvest now a lot of
viruses producing eggs and then you
inactivate the virus and you purified
partially in the humic routine and
neuraminidase and this is what is being
used as the inactivated influenza
vaccines they are based on the
hemagglutinin of the secret in viruses
because the citrulline viruses change a
micro teeny chains and then you need to
update the vaccine almost every year and
you need to take it every year and again
even in pandemic virus has to go through
all this process again and because of
that you don't have the time to fight
against the virus during the first wave
for a vaccine against the virus so the
question is can we develop a better
vaccine a vaccine that will be able to
prevent infection with any influence of
ours and this is same strategy that we
are now trying to sprawl in
collaboration with better policy I'm
Lauren Kramer two investigators also
here in one side now this the concept
that we have is based on targeting areas
in the bars that are completely
conserved and what we are targeting
specifically is a region in the
hemagglutinin which is here in red that
is called the stem of the hemagglutinin
the stem of the human routine is very
well conserved but it does not generate
too many antibodies most of them
Peabody's they are generating
the help here in blue which they are
very good antibodies but that is trend
specific they had change from year to
year and therefore the antibodies that
you develop it for one year didn't work
now for them the strain does country
next year
now the antibodies that one gets by
natural infection by vaccination against
the stem which are more conserved they
are very few
so we try to come up with strategies
that will be able to induce more levels
of antibodies your system that we then
use the vaccines that they are right now
being used or whether they induce
natural infection with influenza virus
and for that we use an approach that we
call it repeated vaccination with
Kemetic
HD vaccines and I'm going to show you
how this approach in this protection of
antibodies against multiple subtypes of
influenza virus and that's in
collaboration again with Peter policy
run the outbreak and Florian Kramer here
on silent now the concept is based on
the following we make a chimeric
influenza virus comic routine a chimeric
one is one that contains the stem from a
circulating influenza virus in this case
is three and a head which is in purple
and a head here in green that comes from
an exotic a jnh for humans they have
never been exposed to it fourth we
continue with now exposure to different
hemagglutinin that has a head for mates
five and stemmed from from the same a
three and then at the end with another
retain that is different but contains
also the same different head but same
stem and at the end we challenge with
the virus that does not have this
completely different subtype but cells
the conserva stem of the history
hemagglutinin so what happened when we
do this vaccination in mice the first
vaccination in these million people is
against the head but if we antibodies
against the stem now when we repeat it
because the antibodies against the stem
they are nine memory B cells we are
boosting these cells from when using
more antibodies against the stem
while we are priming again against a new
head that is different from the green
head and now when we come with the next
camera came a protein we boost even more
than T bodies against the stem that is
common but again we do only primary
response against the head
so when we come back with a challenge
that is only seven in nine that has the
same stem then the mice are protected
that's what happened here we see here
that animals that are not vaccinated
they die while animals that are in that
are vaccinated even with a vaccine that
is marching over the schematic a chase
they have been protected against without
challenge with influenza virus but they
are protected not only against 8:7 their
protect against age ten with a reduction
in titles in lungs against h3 is either
spineless trees or human is trees and in
fact there are protect against all group
to hem agglutinins with Murthy included
is for fourteen three fifteen seven and
ten now the reason elect set of chemical
team is group 1 including the H ones
that they are not protected against with
a group two vaccine but we can protect
it in which is the same approach with
Group one vaccines so if we use now in a
strategy based on a chimeric nine one
four win by six one four eight I five
one where it's protecting is h101 and by
doing this Bible in vaccines a group two
and a group one we should be able to
prevent any influenza virus infection if
we are done that influenza B and we
should be able to prevent any influence
infection now the protection is antibody
mediated so we get high levels of
antibodies measured by allies against
the stand by this committee in my
glutamine vaccination and we just take
the antibodies and put it back into new
mais the animals are protector also
against charge now based on this data we
started a prime boost vaccination using
a live attenuated influenza virus
vaccine that is been used in some
countries followed by the inactivated
vaccine also that is being widely used
but based on this chimera hemagglutinin
and we first did an experiment in
ferrets in which we use a nine one four
eight eight one and for me by five one
either as live attenuated vaccines or
inactivated vaccines so we have a
different groups one the code that gives
the life eternal vaccine for waiting
she married another group that has been
activated for it i inactivated one that
is a control group and we compare it
with the actual inactivity vaccine that
is called TIV and I ferret now again I
said mention ferrets are a good model
for influenza virus infection now when
we challenge now with the virus that is
pandemic h1n1 this does not have any of
the heads of this of the other vaccine
the first thing that we see is that
there is a good levels of antibodies in
this against the stock by the Kemetic
vaccines is it in blue or in green that
are high levels of antibodies after the
after the last boost and when we
challenged with pandemic h1n1 then we
get a nice reduction by the Kemetic
vaccines especially they want this life
attenuated followed by inactivated in
trachea in the nose and in the bronchi
and that's better than what we get for
example with inactivated influenza virus
vaccine
alright so encouraged by these things we
have performed now a human trial phase 1
trial is still for look into safety and
immunogenicity of these type of vaccines
that are being funded has been funded by
the Bill Gates Foundation which we use a
very similar approach that one in
ferrets we compare a life attenuated
follow it by inactivated that would be
Group 1 group Chui is also live
attenuated plus an activity but in the
case of Group 1 is with an adjuvant ASO
3 and in the case of group choice
without active and inactivated vaccine
so the arguments are supposed to give
very many initiated to the vaccine we
have a group a placebo group and then we
have a group for that has inactivated
for we'd apply inactivated chimeric
vaccines and a group 5 that is placebo
the live attenuated vaccines we put in
isolation units to prevent potential
spread of life attenuated virus which at
the end we found that that's not the
case this virus does not propagate
between different vaccinated or not
vaccinated individuals and now I saw did
the trial a design overview is here
it was a prospective randomized control
phase 1 trial healthy
male and female adults 18 to 39 years of
age 69 subjects 39 was done in puke and
26 in Cincinnati hospital randomized to
one of five groups median age 29 years
for a female 25 female we didn't see any
adverse event and what we were able now
is to look for levels of antibodies
against the stop so in placebo
individuals we find some basal levels
with stalk antibodies that are we don't
think that enough for protection now we
use an approach that is space or life
attenuated followed by by inactivating
we see that after life attenuated there
is no so much thing happening but after
one gives the boost with the inactivated
one start to see antibodies against this
talk of the tail
if one use a inactivity I developed it
won't get even a better boost and the
best results we have it when we use
inactivated adjuvanted for brain
activity at 20 we get a very good
response with the first vaccine against
the stalk of the che the comes back a
little bit comes down but then gets
boosted again by the second and these
levels of antibodies we know that they
are protective of disease in animal
models but this is not only against H
ones we see that these antibodies
cross-react with a choose with each
nines with 818 with basically every
group one human routine so we are very
encouraged by this data showing that
there is the potential that such type of
vaccines will be able to provide
protection Hemans against any different
subtype of influenza virus so in
conclusion I show you that sequential
vaccination with chimera hemagglutinin
vaccines in the setting esteem
antibodies and current levels of
protection against kettles a typical
ease in animals and that these can be
also induce in humans in this phase 1
clinical trial yes 1a saw a picture of
my lab we call ourselves the flu virus
or the virus virus
and some of the agencies contributed to
finance in the world the work that I
presented here Barda dsk we have been
collaborating with yes k NIH in us that
is funded a center of excellence and
influence services and surveillance that
we call
Sheils as well as path on the bill
melinda gates foundation that have been
funding the clinical trials that i saw
so thanks a lot